Avengers in game took secrecy to all new
levels with its intentionally spoiler
free marketing efforts once the movie
was released though the behind the
scenes info began pouring out here are
some of the most interesting things to
emerge it's a well-known fact that
directors Joe and Anthony Russo will go
to extreme lengths to keep their marvel
creations under wraps for example they
teasingly apologized to the spoiler
prone Tom Holland for dusting Spidey at
the end of infinity war and consequently
keeping him at arm's length for the
promotion of endgame
they also pretended to fire Mark Ruffalo
after a string of spoilers had put him
on thin ice one of the best methods for
keeping everyone in the dark though was
the way the Russos handled the script
most of the actors got only pieces of
the screenplay to work from and
apparently Ruffalo got a particularly
spoiler proof of the script the hulk
actor was only given a partial script
with additional dummy scenes in it
according to an interview with E news I
don't know what's gonna happen
I like shot five different endings I
didn't even get a whole script but even
that didn't stop him from accidentally
giving something away in that same
interview he joked about what he
presumably thought was one of those
dummy scenes his spoiler they have to
throw mark off the scent oops
endgame is the second MCU outing for
Carol Danvers who arrived on the scene
just weeks earlier in her own superhero
flick Captain Marvel for actress brie
Larson though that wasn't the case
Larson had filmed her scenes for endgame
before she ever had a chance to flesh
out the character in her own film as an
added twist the first scene she ever
filmed was set during the events of
endgame but technically ended up in
Captain Marvel on The Tonight Show
Larson recalled that her first day of
filming was for the end credits scene
for her own film which showed her
arriving at the Avengers facility post
snap where's fury I didn't know that was
a tag for Captain Marvel I didn't know
what that was that we were shooting was
also nobody else there in true Russo
fashion though the actress was only
given her lines and filmed her part
alone in front of a green screen that's
taking secrecy to a whole new level
while the Russo brothers bent over
backwards to keep actors like Ruffalo
Holland and Larson from spoiling the
script there was
person that they didn't mind showing the
whole thing to Robert Downey jr. while
discussing infinity war and in game in
an interview with Rotten Tomatoes the
pair talked about keeping things secret
our DJ was probably the only one to
actually read the entire script part of
our motivation to do that is it just
takes a lot of pressure off of people
everything had started with Iron Man
just a decade earlier with end game
ultimately serving as the iron Avengers
swan song it's only appropriate that our
DJ would be trusted with some of the
most sensitive MCU knowledge to ever
exist when the Avengers break into teams
for their time heist in in-game rocket
and four are sent to Asgard during the
events of Thor the dark world to
retrieve the reality stone at that point
in time the stone is using the god of
thunders X Jane Foster as a host foster
who's been absent for Marvel films since
the dark world appears on screen a few
times before rocket is able to get the
reality stone out of her but it turns
out that foster actress Natalie Portman
didn't actually film any new footage for
endgame in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly the Russos
explained that they had been able to
salvage unused footage from the dark
world in order to get all of the scenes
they needed while the footage was enough
for them to work with they did ask the
actress to record a small bit of
voice-over in the days after endgame lit
up the theater marquees star-lord actor
Chris Pratt stirred up attention by
releasing a video he'd taken on set
while preparing for one of the film's
key action sequences the once in a
lifetime video showed nearly all of the
famous actors mostly in sweats and
comfortable clothing chatting and
discussing their scenes as casually as
if they were a group of high schoolers
hanging out after class the video gave a
unique glimpse into the inner workings
of a film that had been kept tightly
under wraps since day one
Stan Lee was a comic book Titan for over
half a century while he was an important
creative mind behind the scenes for
decades his long relationship with
Marvel also led to a memorable series of
fan favorite cameos throughout various
Marvel movies when Lee passed away in
late 2018 fans began theorizing about
when his last cameo would surface a year
earlier it had been revealed that Lee
had filmed five different cameos for
upcoming films the fact that he was
apparently batching his cameos naturally
left the possibility that he could be
popping into films for an indefinite
amount of
I'm endgame delivered a shot of a
younger looking hippie version of me
driving by the 1970s shield headquarters
shouting make love not war as it turned
out that scene will be Lee's last ever
cameo and it's a fitting farewell the
Russos confirmed after the fact that
it's the last Stan Lee cameo that made
it to film in a twist that few people
saw coming in in game Natasha Romanov
ended up sacrificing herself for the
soulstone it was a beautifully
redemptive way to end her own heroic
story which had been going on in the
background for nearly the entire MCU but
of course this is Marvel and there's
always the question of whether they'll
bring her back with Gamora zari entrance
into the future from the past in endgame
anything is possible
except not with Romanoff her story seems
closed for good this time
screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely explained to the New
York Times her journey and our minds had
come to an end if she could get the
Avengers back she has a chance to get
them back that's the thing she would
trade for during her memorial scene on
the dock the surviving heroes
conversation drove home the point that
the cost of the soul stone is a
permanent one while there's no doubt
that Black Widow will be remembered by
fans for years to come she's gone for
good
except presumably for her upcoming movie
while Black Widow may have ultimately
been given a powerful closing to her own
story Romanovs death wasn't always a
sure thing after all movies aren't
completely finished until the release
date the shwarma end credits scene from
Avengers wasn't even added until the
week that the film was released so it
should come as no surprise that there
was a lot of shifting and changing as
they went along one of those changes the
events on Boromir writers Markus and
McFeely explained that there was a
version of the script that had Clint
Barton sacrificing himself for the stone
instead of Romanov but when they gave
the scene to the visual effects producer
Jim underdahl she apparently told them
don't you take this away from her the
response clearly impacted the writers
who ultimately acknowledged that it had
to be Romanoff it turns out the Markus
and McFeely have had a working master
document since Captain America Civil War
where they kept track of different
things they wanted to do with their
hero's character arcs it turns out that
endgame was the movie where they got to
run wild in particular McFeely said that
they wanted to explore Marvel's Trudeau
what if comics alternate-universe
presentations of Marvel events playing
out differently
the writers delve in and incorporated a
bunch of what-if scenarios right into
the in-game plot the writers told the
New York Times well this is our what if
if you lost four becomes fat natasha
becomes a shut-in steve becomes
depressed tony gets on with his life
Hulk is a superhero Clint becomes a
murdering maniac
while there were solid reasons for every
characters shift in tone there's no
doubt that the writers were happy to
push the heroes out of their comfort
zone for the entertainment of all
infinity war and in game maybe two
distinctly different movies but the
subject matter that they handle is
clearly interwoven this left the writers
and directors constantly scrambling to
figure out how to puzzle a bunch of
different pieces of storyline together
in a coherent way that left them with
two distinct yet connected movies at one
point the plan was to have Hulk and
banner resolve their differences in
infinity war however it felt like too
much of a positive in the middle of a
pretty sad ending so the filmmakers
bumped into endgame they also left out
the actual transformation banking on
Scott Lang in the dinner scene to
provide the right amount of confusion to
help bridge the gap in the same vein
Hawk eyes opening scene in endgame where
he loses his family was nearly tacked
onto the end of infinity war but it once
again felt out of place the biggest
decision of all was where to place the
snap they debated putting it earlier an
infinity war but it would have left
almost nothing for the ending on the
other hand if they pushed it to endgame
it would have left the first movie with
no ending at all knowing when to reverse
the snap was nearly as challenging
thankfully the creative minds behind the
scenes managed to eventually pull it all
together into two coherent stories Scott
Lang was right in-game is a time heist
movie it wasn't the writers who came up
with that one though but Marvel boss
Kevin Feige himself psyches original
suggestion was to use time travel to
resolve an infinity war plot with the
centerpiece being the time stone it
wasn't until the filmmakers began
fleshing things out that the quantum
realm became the key plot device to move
the time travel element forward once
time travel was in the mix there was one
obvious point that had to make it into
the film the Battle of New York but the
writers initially felt it was too
pandering
to head back to the original Avengers
film so they tried a ton of alternatives
first at one point they had Tony Stark
on Asgard in a stealth suit fighting
Heimdall and the planet Morag was
originally underwater at another point
the Avengers stopped by Triskelion and
even hopped in a car to visit dr.
strange when the rubber hit the road
though writers and directors alike
finally decided that heading back to the
Chitauri infested streets of New York
was the best option of the bunch
the sequence in end game when our heroes
put their heist plan to the test shows
the time travel within the MCU is
distinctly different than the way it's
been represented in movies like Timecop
Hot Tub Time Machine or Back to the
Future
Time Machine it also establishes that
Pym particles are in extremely limited
supply Tony Stark and Steve Rogers head
back on a potentially one-way trip to
the 70s in the hope of scrounging up
more particles just to keep everything
from falling apart this left fans
scratching their heads when nebula
casually brought Thanos his entire
planet size ship in its massive army
into the present where on earth did they
get the impossibly huge number of
particles to pull off a stuff like that
Joe Russo cleared up to disconnect in an
interview offering an elegantly simple
solution when 2014 nebula surrenders the
Pym particles to her father they aren't
for him to use to time-travel they're
for scientific research
Thanos a genius himself with the help of
the powerful sorcerer ebony maw studied
the Pym particles and then mass-produced
them in order to defeat the avengers
once and for all check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the Avengers are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one